I'm not writing a chronicle of the wars following the death of King Robert the first so he can sit from his shelf unread
What, you don't like the title? What would you call it?
Hey, YouTubers. It's Charlie. This is going to be my Episode 2 Q&A just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet
And if you are finding me for the first time I do game of thrones videos every week be sure to subscribe to get everything
So here we go first question cloof asks. Do you think that jon snow is fireproof since he's been resurrected by the red
God yet kissed by fire
I think it's an interesting idea that he might be in that's a way for them to prove these targaryen later in the show
But that's still one of the many theories for proving who he is
There's so much backstory and mythology that they still have to spell out like they have to connect the dots
what happened between Rhaegar and Lyanna did they get married before they had Jon Snow is he a
Legitimate child the pace at which the show typically goes suggests that we won't get answers for this till the final episode
But they'll slowly start hinting at it and do remember that the TV show has taken a dramatically different
Route than the books when explaining. Why people are fireproof like why Daenerys is constantly fireproof?
That's not the case in the book so when you're thinking about Jon
Snow potentially having attributes like other targaryens like Daenerys
Just use the evidence that you've seen on the TV show so far next question Jimmy asks
I can't believe dollar said hasn't sent a raven to Jon about brand yet, Meanwhile
He's getting letters from Sam and Tyrion it would seem important to tell the king that his brother is alive. Yes
I think this is a totally valid
Criticism of the show the way they disseminate information to characters you have people like Cersei who have little birds everywhere
So it does make sense that she would have all the information about what's going on all over the kingdom
But they've been kind of inconsistent with the way they give information to all these characters like how is it that Jon snow knows about?
Everything that's going on in the south, but he doesn't know that brand has arrived yet, the main reason
I think is because brand has so many answers
And they don't want to reveal that information or have characters learn about it till much later in the show
So it's totally valid to criticize the show for picking plot over logic
It's another one of those Sansa telling jon snow about the knights of the vale thing back from season six
Next question hobo Deluxe s did you notice the sea was frozen at Eastwatch-By-the-sea?
During the opening map sequence that was new looks like the night's king is close to there or there already
So I think what's going on there is want to show you that winter is slowly
Encroaching on the south the big theory is that after episode one in that?
Deleted hound scene where he said the waves are frozen that people are like
Maybe the night king is just going to walk around the wall. I don't think it's going to be all about that
There's a lot of funny stuff going on with the map this season things that they're changing things that they should have changed like swapping
Out the stag sigil for the lions digital now that sir. She is queen but as for the wall
I think they're just showing you that
Winter is now spreading everywhere like you have to imagine that eventually this might cover the entire globe if the night King wins the game
Of thrones I think even if they don't bring the entire wall crashing down they'll at least bring a portion of it down
But when we actually get to that moment if we get to that this season we can talk about why they may have chosen this
Route rather than has the night king just come down the middle through castle black
next question
Ahmed asks now that Yara
Greyjoy's been captured how does that impact the iron fleet and who will support the Tyrells as they lay siege to King's landing?
well, I think the idea is that the tyrells are going to be busy down in Highgarden because they were going to use part of
The Ironborn fleet to Ferry everyone around to King's landing for that siege Tyrians plan is
Effectively in ruins now with the exception to the unsullied being casterly rock
The original plan was to send Yara down with the ironborn portion of the fleet to dorne to grab the dornish Troops
Bring them up in at the same time the tyrells would start marching on King's landing - so cersei would effectively be
Boxed in on all three sides here with the exception of the North because jon Snow's doing his own thing right now
But now that we've lost Yara's fleet the dornish can't get to King's landing in time
and
We know that Jamie is making a bee line with the lannister army down to Highgarden so I don't think there are going to be
Any highgarden soldiers making it up to King's landing to fight against Cersei
Next question shell asks do you think that if Arya kills Littlefinger with without Santa that we might see Arya?
We're little fingers faced there are a couple questions about the way arya wears faces how the TV shows change things
I don't think that she's going to be wearing littlefinger space
This is another one of those fuzzy book logic situations where the TV shows?
Dramatically changed the mythology and you just to take into account that stuff that they presented so far
Yes, just based on the TV show rules
she would be able to wear little fingers face because he's not too different in size from Walder frey and if she could do with
his face
she could do with another and yes that is a really interesting way to get the help of the sweet robin because
Littlefinger controls the sweet Robin the sweet Robin effectively controls the veil even though he's a puppet leader
I think the idea is that Yohn Royce and the other lords of the vale would back Sansa up
they really liked her but I think that everybody both in the north and in the Vale will be happy to get rid of
Littlefinger so if they have the threat of the white Walkers
I don't think they're going to be too many problems and getting the Vale to help out after Littlefingers gone
Next question Frank asks is Yara dead who was hanging from the ship?
So two of the sand snakes died the ones it's hanging from the ship is
Nymeria Yara was taken by Euron just to clarify they seemed like there were a couple questions about which of the sand snakes died
what did your on do with them after he captured them so Tyene and
Ilaria and Yara Greyjoy were all captured and taken back to King's landing
We'll find out what they're going to do with them next week the dead ones are nymeria and Obara
They're the only ones that they left behind so you see Obara lying on the ship you see that you're on hung
Nymeria with her whip which is sort of Poetic justice?
Depending on how you look at it next one lilith asks you mentioned the characters talk a lot about Aegon's conquest
And Robert's rebellion
Do you think they do it because we might be getting these events and spin-offs?
So they've actually clarified George are Martin specifically clarified that Robert's rebellion is not going to be one of the shows that they're developing
None of the four shows are supposed to be set
Forward in time all of them seem to be said in the past so it's more technically correct to call them
Prequels like ancient Valyria is one of the strong candidates, but the other one that Martin confirmed
They're not doing is Dunk & Egg because he's still writing those stories
And he says he doesn't want them to do a show based on stuff that he's not finished writing yet next one erik asks
Why didn't Sam give Jorah milk of the poppy he had all that other stuff?
Available to help fix them why not milk of the poppy
so I think the idea is that he was going based on the
Instructions in that secret book the forbidden technique in milk of the poppy might not have been on that list
They didn't say anything specifically about dragonglass see just wheels that card in you don't see exactly what it is
He's doing what kind of concoction?
He's going to create, but hopefully they'll answer that in next week's episode
But they have a tendency to brush over big things like that
So we can theory craft after next week
Next one Jimmy asks did anyone also think that the principal's promise will be the child of Jon and Daenerys who will play a role somehow?
This is actually why I made that Melisandre fanfiction Joke in my episode 2 video because we're getting into John Daenerys territory
It's going to get a little bit nuts right now in the books and on the TV show Daenerys believes that she's Barren me
Remaster told her that after she lost her baby Rhaego with Khal Drogo. That was it
She was not going to have any more children, so I think that they're physically capable of having a baby, but as for that
Baby being the prince who was promised who will bring the dawn?
I think
Part of the idea is that the characters on the show right now the ones that survive to the end will be the ones that
Helped bring the dawn, and there's no one prince or princess
It's just like a group of special people that will bring the dawn primarily jon
Snow engineers together so it's not necessarily evidence
Against them having a baby that could also be the prince who was promised if you really want to back that
Dragon you can ride that to the end of the show
It's still wide open to theory crafting but I don't think we're going to see any of that kind of stuff play out during season
7 next question Muhammad asks is Drogon larger than Balerion
Know the reason why Drogon isn't as big yet is because he's way younger
Balerion lived to be almost
About 200 years old and he roam free there are a couple of key things that dragons need in order to continue growing
There's no limit on their size
They'll just keep getting bigger and bigger as long as they have a plentiful enough food source
And they're allowed to roam free so when the targaryen put them in the dragon pit and started caging them up
That's when dragons slowly
Started to die out so the idea is that if Drogon keep surviving keeps eating keeps roaming free he'll continue to get as big
Maybe if he lives to be 200 years old he'll also be as big as Balerion the black dread
Next question top shelf asks. Do you think that Cersei will pull a mad king on a Lauria and her daughter?
So you're talking about burn one of them alive? I think if anybody is going to be burning people alive, it'll be Daenerys
I definitely think that cersei is going to kill one or both of those sand snakes
But I things that she's going to borrow the mad king style
I think they want to play up Daenerys is
potential mad queen as a bit of a
Misdirect for what might end up happening at the end of the season?
I still think that the show is backing Daenerys is one of the big protagonists, so in reality
She is not the mad queen but in the way that they're hyping up this false conflict between John and Sansa
They're doing the same thing by misdirecting you making you think that Daenerys might do something crazy
Next question Jackie asks what do you think about the possibility of Dany and Jon getting married to form an alliance? Yeah?
This is going to be one of those things that people just go nuts over until the end of the season
I don't think that Daenerys and John will get married this season. If that's what you're asking. It seems like what they'll do is
They'll just slowly develop their relationship over time this season
And then who knows all bets are off in season eight
Depending on how things go down during the war for the dog because it seems like there's going to be a big battle every single
Episode that season there won't be a whole lot of time for thinking about marriage or children so all I'm really expecting
This season is that they'll just grow to admire each other by the end of the season and they'll grow much closer
Mutual respect maybe there'll be some chemistry between the two of them, but I don't think the show is going to go straight to
relationship or
Even answer the question of Jon Snow's
Parentage in a way that all the characters know like I don't think that jon snow will know that
He's a targaryen by the end of the season, and I don't think that Daenerys will know either
But thank you so much for so many questions
These are always a ton of fun to do there'll be more bonus videos later this week
There's still a couple of comic-con videos that I'm trying to finish by the end of this week before we get into the weekend
So just leave all your requests in the comments below but congratulations to the latest Giveaway winner Kim Bishop
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
Click here for the trailer for episode 3 and click here for my episode 2 video
Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight